So how might we think about creating
some channels that make it easier to
separate these things?
Well we already saw this from
our previous conversation.
Let's separate out the intensity
from the color, okay?
So the first thing we're going to do,
it we're going to define intensity Y as
some combination of R, G, and B, okay?
And so
that gives you this nice picture here.
And those of you that are old enough
to remember black and white television,
you start to be thinking,
oh, wait a minute,
this is like an image that just reflects
the overall intensity of what's there.
And that would be correct, all right?
And in fact, a luminance function,
which is what this called,
is just a linear weight of the red,
green and blue pixels.
Here are weights of red, green and blue.
And by combining them together,
I get a single value Y, for luminance.
Remember, Y stands for luminance for
reasons that are,
because it's the middle of X, Y, Z.
That's why.
All right, so
now I need the two other values, right?
I mean I could just keep the R,
G and then try to reconstruct them.
But instead what they do is they
compute a different color space.
Then this is called the YUV colorspace.
And here's a,
a computation that takes the B values,
the Y values, and
creates a new value called U and V.
And a way of thinking about this is
one of them has to do with sort of
the difference between
the luminance in blue.
And the other one is the difference
between luminance in red and
it matches and
it creates this thing called UV.
And the thing that you need,
that you need to know is that U and
V contain the color information.
So they tell you that they're
giving you an image in YUV space,
you know that UV contain the,
the chromatic the color information.
And by the way in this YUV mapping,
there's a maximum and
minimum that U and V can get maxed to.
And that's why it's called Umax and
Vmax.
And we assume the R,
G, B range from 0 to 1.
Okay, if it goes from zero to 255
you just scale the whole thing.
All right, when you create that you
can actually make three images, right?
You can make a Y image,
a U image and a V image and
that would look like this, all right?
So the Y image is ju, exactly what
you're used to seeing in your black and
white television.
But your U image and your V image,
those contain the color elements.
Now you might ask,
well why aren't they in color?
>> Why aren't they in color?
>> Because each one of them
is a single channel, okay?
Right, so that's the U.
So the brighter it is, the higher U,
the lower it is, the, the less U.
Same thing with V.